welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight at the
core of any political campaign is the
message what it's about what exactly our
next Tuesday's midterm elections about
when the one side is pretty clear Donald
Trump who's the leader of the Republican
Party and in effect it's only spokesman
says that a vote for Republican
candidates is a vote for secure borders
and against crime and chaos you don't
have to believe the president when he
says this but that's definitely what
Republicans are running on what are
Democrats running on that's less clear
against Trump certainly Democrats talk
about the president even more than he
talks about himself which is a lot they
don't like him at all fine but despising
someone isn't really a platform or a
path forward at best it's a reaction
what are the ideas that unite the
Democratic Party right now well for the
answer to that we go to the other cable
stations which over the past couple of
years have come to function much as the
DNC used to function as the Democratic
Party's brain trust and mouthpiece if
you want to know what Democrats are
thinking watch CNN and MSNBC last night
was especially instructive here are two
contributors to MSNBC one writes for the
New York Times the other is a professor
at Princeton which is an Ivy League
college in New Jersey
both have impressive credentials both
are considered deep thinkers by most of
the other people in this country who
think of themselves as intellectuals
watch as they explain what they've
learned since the 2016 election what I
did wrong in 2016 is that over estimated
white people
I didn't think white people would put
him in office I'm not willing to let
white voters off the hook I think that
they like the rest of us should be
treated as adults and I think that there
are a large number I would say a
majority of white Americans in this
country who are not just Democrats but
who are people of conscience were good
Americans and I believe that they need
to move from saying well I don't like
his tweets but you know the economy's
doing okay I mean they need to move from
there to reality which is that we have a
white nationalist president who's a
threat to American democracy now there
was a time not so long ago just a few
years ago really when language
like this was considered textbook race
hatred even by Liberal Democrats you
weren't allowed to blame entire races of
people for anything you weren't even
supposed to think of your fellow
Americans primarily in terms of their
race and skin color is one thing that
nobody can control to paraphrase a
longtime liberal hero whose ideas are
now ignored what matters is the content
of a person's character but not anymore
now the opposite is true identity is
everything here CNN's Don Lemon on
Monday night so we have to stop
demonizing people and realize the
biggest terror threat in this country is
white men most of them radicalized run
up to the right and we have to start
doing something about them there is no
travel ban on them there is no ban on
you know they had the Muslim ban there
is no white guy ban so what do we do
about that we have to start doing
something about them these people of a
certain skin color
that's what Don Lemon said now before
you get too outraged about that and stop
watching his show every night keep in
mind that Don Lemon is a cable news host
he's on television 5 hours a week alive
he's bound to say something indefensible
once in a while they all do we can
actually vouch for that having done it
ourselves
unfortunately but here are the rules
when you say something awful that you
can't defend don't try to defend it
apologize explain what you meant and
move on how to do better that's a rule
for life not just television news we all
learned it as kids on the Left though it
no longer applies here's what Don Lemon
said last night about his remarks on
Monday I said that the biggest terror
threat in this country comes from
radicals on the far right primarily
white men that angered some people their
analysis shows that for every eight
deadly attacks by right-wing wing
extremists there were one by left-wing
extremists those are the facts so people
who were angered about what I said are
missing the entire point we don't need
to worry about people who are thousands
of miles away the biggest threats are
homegrown if you didn't like what I said
that's your problem you'll notice the
lack of contrition when Don Lemon said
we have to start doing something about
Americans of a certain skin color turns
out it wasn't a mistake he meant that he
didn't apologize because nobody in his
world asked him to they're all saying
pretty much the same thing this is now a
common view in the Democratic Party it's
one of the things they're running on now
lots of Americans won't like that
message obviously but Democrats are not
concerned about that they no longer care
what those Americans think they've given
up on trying to represent them and
that's why they fight harder to defend
birthright citizenship for foreigners
than they ever fought to protect
American citizens from heroin or
plunging middle-class wages or privacy
destroying tech monopolies they know who
their constituency is that also explains
their sudden sympathy for lawbreakers
over everyone else you already know
about the Democrats demand that America
ignore its own immigration laws but it's
gone far beyond that Elizabeth Warren is
the senator from Massachusetts and is
running for president in 2020 has
condemned our entire criminal justice
system as irredeemably racist meanwhile
the Hollywood Senate candidate baito
or orc agrees with that he's called our
justice system quote the new Jim Crow he
accused cops of shooting people based on
their skin color now he offered no
evidence that cops do shoot people just
based on their skin color he didn't need
to because he just knows it's true
meanwhile democratic cities around the
country have decided that laws against
crimes like shoplifting and public
urination and others can no longer be
enforced because that would be racist
now the results of all of this is
inevitable it's always the same
everywhere more crime and you already
seeing that in many places
turns out the victims are not cloistered
rich people like baito
or orc they're normal people of all
races crime hurts everyone but it tends
to hurt the poor the most if that's
occurred to Democrats they haven't
mentioned it they're feeling good about
themselves right now they know they're
likely to win back the house on Tuesday
and they're feeling vindicated more
self-righteous than ever
we searched long and hard today for a
piece of tape that could sum up the
Democratic worldview right now and we
found this it was shot by a network
cameraman covering the president's trip
to the Tree of Life synagogue in
Pittsburgh
this week the protesters screaming at
the president happens to be a
Presbyterian minister watch it's not
about yo cut the families grieve this is
our neighborhood you are not welcome
here
[Music]
this is our neighborhood we woke up
everybody here you're not welcome here
we welcome everybody well it's pretty
much the whole Democratic message right
there will at work maybe on Tuesday
maybe for a little while on glue merkel
tried it in germany so did the people
who until recently ran brazil but
ultimately their countries rejected that
message voters want you to care about
them it's their country and they'll know
it if you don't care about them and in
the end they will punish you for that
they always do